on this episode black coffee stops by
[Music]
you
[Music]
this is
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and it's nothing 255 we
think of the askgaryvee show we are in a
beautiful setting here in Conn at the
advertising festival but way more
important than that we're hanging with
some of our favorite friends but way
more important than that we have music
superstars black coffee in the house
with this epic light blue pants and as
massive skills glass knocking women
first of all not greatness for you why
don't you tell the Vayner nation that's
watching right now you know for the
people who have been living under a rock
before we get into the questions that
are coming through Facebook great to see
you start firing away your questions why
don't you tell for a Miller to not only
what you do but a little bit of the
backstory which I'm very fond of how
you've gotten to this point and what you
do for a living so fire away
I basically am a music guy born in South
Africa static music chopped out started
a band dropped out
started my solo career and then music
producer and DJ been doing this for like
over 10 years now yeah that's how that's
it so on a very serious note what's
really interesting is I'm fortunate
enough to hang out a lot of fun people
but the selfie that you and I took 18
months ago the passion of your audience
is so incredible when people saw that we
were hanging out together they're like
it blew their mind and I've been
following along since they have met you
with your career things that nature
it's incredible to watch the passion
that your fanbase has why do you think
you've broken out and actually because
again I want to make sure people know
how do you define your genre cuz I think
you do it a little bit different and I
want to just hear from the horse's mouth
how do you find your style of DJing in
English I just call it how to really you
know one guy literally yesterday was
asking me you know and I know it's hot
what kind of heart and I try not to go
there I'm being this yeah I don't want
me feel like you keep on yeah I don't
want to be pigeonholed into into any
genre or politics I just call it how to
use it and it's different at times with
tribal sometimes with Africa and
sometimes it can be more are beach more
house but it is house music so well
actually let's take a step back what do
you realize as a youngster you love
music was it when you were right away
from the moon like later in life when
all the kids basically I loved dancing
to music and then growing up one of my
cousins and befriended like a mobile
disco sound system I should go with them
connected system and parties and you
know anything that had music out visa
you know I didn't know what I really
wanted to do when they introduced the
music class in school I was the first
one to go in them still I didn't know
you know I went to study now listen to
the music next door after it said music
and even then I didn't know what I would
do you know but there was a music studio
which I really loved working on music
production more than anything and I
think that's where the production was
that I know shaping up and and as you
were going through this music journey
who are the one two three you know
influences he's making your music life
always fascinated by since people listen
to or what was the song or who is the
produce like what were some of those
Keystone individuals and or moments in
your music journey I think as a at an
early age you know I just sort of had
visualized myself on a global scale
you know I said like dreams of then
working with Michael Jackson and the kid
in in Africa you know I have like a
dream about him and me being friends and
he would come to South Africa for a show
and would hang out and you know I think
he's one of the people that played a
major role you know I listen to none of
the stuff but he was still the kid
control very early and just watch his
career and many others you know but from
in any age I'm always had but global
ambition you know it's funny you have a
piece of content that caught my
attention where it's a drone coming in
and out and you reference you reference
there I think as a kid you know I
daydreamed a lot I was in my head a lot
the amount of seconds up so is that what
you would do it like when you were
sitting there like is that what you were
just doing like you were like reading it
out like you a picturing what it was
going to look like with you and Michael
Jackson being homeless video
it wasn't crazy like therefore you guys
were you like in California and every
way I wanted all the new township in
South Africa almost rural place called
the instant ate almost almost rule I say
that because my grandmother had cloud so
I grew up milking cows literally and on
holidays I would be like the shepherd
boy and look after the cloud and that's
what I did daydreaming was taking place
like in the field when I'm sitting with
the car and that's how spend the holiday
before we get into some of the questions
that are coming through on social what
uh what was kind of the you know rape
you know it's obviously Bennis you know
overnight success takes your whole life
but what was was there a you know
there's a lot of entrepreneurs that are
watching a lot of creators a lot of
artists I think for everybody there is
always like moments they might not you
know for me I never think of it as like
the one thing but it's for like seven or
ten or eleven everything's you remember
the first thing that kind of changed the
album obviously you mentioned earlier
you tried a couple things in the past
they didn't work out for the thing that
did work out was there did somebody put
you onto somebody's play a song what was
the moment where you first tasted okay
there's something happening here I think
when I got accepted to study music at a
university level I then thought it's
okay I might have something so there are
the most weird thing for me I can't
really think but they interviewed me as
a singer so they asked me to sing and
that's how I got in so I majored in gel
voice so that for me that was like okay
maybe I do have something you know and
then while we were studying then we
assigned as a pair
by label from London that was also
another step say ok we actually do have
something going those two steps for me
with the most important in terms of just
knowing ok I don't know what I'm doing
but I am in the right direction what
about your relationship with social you
know you have a really substantial
following does that come native to you
as somebody who's been you know sitting
with the cows and in your own head as a
framework has the outward aspect of the
fame or that you know hundreds of
thousands millions of fans that follow
you on these platforms has that come
natural has that something you've had to
develop you like it do not like it but
you recognize the importance in what you
do for living
talk to me about that relationship I
love the relationship right I respect it
a lot I see it as a great platform to
talk to my people a lot
also because I'm hardly in South Africa
anymore you know I times I feel like I'm
detached from everything that's
happening from from the same base and
for me it's very important to be
accessible you know it's very important
for me to talk to them and make them
understand that whatever that I'm doing
they can do it you know so you helped me
close that gap and I'm able to talk like
today in my tweet was what did you do
today to to get closer to the life that
you deserve you know that was my teeth
today and it got a lot of traction
because it was a genuine question you
know and that's what I try and post
about I post about real things
there's a line goal you know there's a
very thin line because there's a real
life and then there's a real personal
life you know and I try to separate it's
a personal thing because I don't think
they'll they'll motivate some people
sometimes they can just kill this as
well you know so I try to be as real as
possible and I use my social media
platform all the time to post things
that can only build because we must
remember I'm from South Africa and we
have a very turbulent part in the
countries and it affected a lot of our
parents and great-grandparents and they
didn't have much to give us you know
given in terms of Drive and motivation
you know so we are building in the
country at the moment we try to find our
feet and it's always important to push
that message but guys remember we we are
far from where the rest of the world is
you know and I you I tried so hard to
use my social media to communicate
trusted link he's gonna ask a question
here tonight the rock soul in here
so right okay
but do you have questions sorry okay
tell her beneficial jack of all trades
being a mountain of fun for me I mean
growing up I use it was definitely my
thing like this is what I do you know
and but I have love for us you know
people of love for for other things you
know and if not everyone can be a master
of everything but if you have the
challenge of being destroyed it boils
down to to to have the talent of doing
other things one of the reasons was wild
Carrie despised me so much is the fact
that he's not just one minded or
his business is only on one direction
you know he does so many different
things and he does all of them
oppression and I think that's the most
important thing and I know so much from
from him and many other people who who
like Virgil upload who's an architect
and a clothing designer and and and so
many other things you know if you have
the talent and the drive to be able to
to master what you know and don't stop
because you are afraid to be tagged as a
master of none and you know I just think
if the college's they go on I'll add on
that I think I think self-awareness
matters so much right like I think that
there's a lot I mean I look at a lot of
you a lot or a little bit from afar I'm
sure we all aspire for other things that
we could have done or wanted to be
especially we were hanging around with
our friends and things that nature but
the reality is you've got to realize
with what I also think that one can
judge it's subjective if you're the
master of a certain thing or you're
doing a whole bunch of different things
so for me I appreciate those kind words
and it's funny for me all all the things
I do and I do so many different things
but ironically for me they're actually
just a heavy reliance on empathy which
then leads to being a good salesman
because we you understand other people
and what they want you're deploying
against that and then I'm just kind of
looking at culture and trends and
deploying those opportunities so I don't
know if I'm doing a jack-of-all-trades
because I'm doing whether it's flying or
advertising or or whatever the heck I'm
doing or am i a master of one which is I
am so deeply entrenched into my
emotional intelligence around one single
thing called empathy that is the speed
that reverses all the way back so I
think even the definition of that I
could I could see myself being either/or
and I think we spend so much time
debating things like that and the people
that ask those kind of questions my
answers always just do sitting around
and pondering the strategy of being a
master or a jack instead of doing is a
huge mistake
how was your father's name my father was
amazing I was home issues last week so I
thought the little tips for anyone from
school the drawing I attended her father
anything at the new one school they kind
of singing and jumping around it was it
was really amazing
I think the Cannes Film Festival is a
terrible festival because it's actually
during father's day and like literally
the fact that they can't move it a week
upsets me greatly so 1/2 a Father's Day
every year because have to jump on a
late claim to get here for all the stuff
that's going on so I like to use this
platform right now to lobby for a push
back by one week's hope somebody here at
the Lions is listening all right this is
a very Russian Jesse K 16 years off from
over 500 manager and yes Jersey of the
house qo1
yeah Wow sharing info question ok Kalyn
hold approve another I rather you should
jump at every opportunity when you're
trying to balance school and business as
much as possible
look in my experience I'll sit down you
know
the sooner you jump the better because
you learn so much from trying and
failing if you don't try now you might
just try a little bit too late you know
so learn now are you picked in by 1811
experience of some sort you know what
was what to take and what not to take
you know it doesn't matter how many you
know and I'm from that school that
always used to calculate and like norm
I'm not ready and with growing up of
less than actually I wasted so much time
on trying to plan things that I don't
even know you know so I go all-in and
I'll get the experience as I and I and I
get on with it
basically I couldn't agree more I I am
you've there's so much more upside than
downside in taking risk at a young age
it's just practical it's practical to go
high-risk high-reward
in your teens and twenties it's just
life practical and I and I think the
reason people don't is they love their
parents or grandparents or somebody in
their life that they don't want to
disappoint by doing the thing that seems
crazy to that elder and you know I don't
want to sit on a pedestal and say you
know do you know do that I understand
what's stopping them I just want to
challenge people to recognize that
regret is very scary and what ends up
happening is you're protecting your
parents feelings in your 20s by doing
the thing you want them to do so how it
manifest is in a relationship in your
40s 50s and 60s with your parents and
less healthy because you start blaming
them for not taking those jumps and so I
feel like you can fight with your
parents now or later and I just think it
works out much better in the upfront
so on the other end of the spectrum the
last viewer is watching all the way Cape
Town South Africa how you feel a
projection
oh yes first you can get yeah and you
know phenomenally I [ __ ] love
rejection I'm so blown away by people's
lack of understanding that battle scars
are attractive like losses are sexy like
I like I like I love using I love
rejection I actually go the other way
when I win I get weird I hated winning
you know facing this up especially we
come for it we're come from you know you
start feeling bad for the guys I get
didn't didn't win and you know but this
is how I started my first album which
came out in 2005 was an album of remixes
and so I went around did my research
asking the guy that was doing what I was
doing what I was trying to do like is it
worth it do an album of remixes like
they're like what do you mean I'm like
if I take the old music that's around
and remix it and rerelease it you know
do you think it would be a success and
everyone was like current dude people
know the song already
you know you wasting your time this is
how it started you know and I felt very
I believed in the idea so much that I
went ahead you know and released an
album as my first album and I wanted an
award for you to know it's my debut
album got me in a world and it was an
album of remixes that I was totally was
never going to make it you know so this
is how I started and I after the same
way about rejection it's always a way
for me to say I think that I'm on the
right track you know the fact that a lot
of people are not understanding because
we live in a world where everyone is
following everyone is following and we
wake up when it's too late someone goes
the other way and they create Facebook
like wow why didn't you think of that in
other words you look back when you first
came with an idea
not if he had put it out there that he
wanted to create such a thing I don't
think many people were able to agree
with him and that's how it is you know I
just think fine power and regret in
rejection you know use that power to pol
you to do even better yeah I mean to me
the way I think I just it's basically a
binary thing I think that people that
are attracted and are obsessed with
musings
tend to win like it's such a counter
intuitive thing like people are always
fascinating why I talk on this subject
matter I don't know I just really like I
love being a Jets fan so much like I
love the losses I love the climb it's
all the journey like I mean on a
personal level and that's one thing I
can't control and that's kind of haha on
a personal level like going into my
dad's liquor store like I wasn't good
enough to get a job somewhere else or
going into the advertising world or Wine
Library TV being in the wine business
doing something that everything
everything I've ever done in my life has
started off with I'm an idiot and I'm a
loser and ended with I'm a genius and on
the waiter and the only way you can
actually do that is that you don't
actually give a [ __ ] about that anybody
else is saying like that's what it comes
down to
you're either the kind of person that
crumbles in other people's opinion about
what you're up to or you're the kind of
person that stays in your own head in a
[ __ ] field with cows or just in your
own head in your bed and realize I've
got this and it's going to taste so much
like I live for I [ __ ] told you I
live for that like I don't mind if
people think that's like weird like like
it's the best feeling I love looking at
people's faces that didn't think and
rolling up like this school I got a
sports agency now my brother and I
decided we're and we're trying to sign
these kids and they're going with much
bigger firms as they should I get it but
if you don't think I can't wait to
Superbowl in four years or the ESPYs in
two years and roll up on these kids and
say you [ __ ] up like like that like
that's what's driving me to take
[ __ ] flights to Toledo to meet their
parents like that literally just the
fact that most people think I'm too busy
doing too many things and I can
so I deal with it tremendously very
relevant when you hit your goal how do
you actually feel feeling worthy do you
think you've answered by good point
I hate hitting goals which is why try
not to make them other than by quick I
genuinely believe the day I buy the New
York Jets is going to be a weird day for
me like what I don't like I don't know
like I don't like hitting goals I don't
like it I actually don't make goals I've
got one that's on the record it's a big
one I'm taking some time yes oh it's a
weird feeling for me as well um I don't
know I think it's a damn the journey is
more exciting you know not knowing
what's going to happen for me it's
always exciting
you know like waking up not sure it's
sort of whether or not I try you know we
keep moving forward you know and I mean
in all interviews for the past five six
years I've been mentioning one name and
like who do you want to collaborate with
like Drake they like refer to doing
house music I also don't know it's going
to how it's going to happen but that's
what I want you know and why not I've
always been saying because I I feel the
kind of how things I will do it is quite
beautiful but it's not accessible or it
doesn't have the Beyonce or the Drake
budgets so it doesn't get too many years
you know but I'm I'm here it's wait and
try and make it work
until we got the call from from take
people one day saying let's do it
you know and when that happened I
couldn't even shades even though it's
something I've been trading at chasing
for four years we have the feeling where
you were pumped for like three minutes
and
can you both of called and people that
would be around me my wife my friends
they all say but you don't know look
excited I are you happy I don't think
yeah you know but I think what makes me
happy is the general you know the next
thing that we are knives yeah
one more length no go ahead a football
gym with the audience - Gary how you
designed the shrine for pebble and
hospice how you designed a high design
inspiration for the motivation must be
different you some inspiration with
present motivation I think please spy
out inspiration can come from just wait
you can pick up on Google and just put
them up and inspire people to motivate
people to get involved you know one of
the things like being in in 2010 just a
year it's a lockdown for talking World
Cup I started a DJ black coffee
Foundation and the launch office because
I wanted to motivate people I set up a
stage in the middle of Soweto in a
shopping center and DJ DJ DJ for 60
hours but from Thursday midnight until
Sunday midday that was motivation
you know for me that the difference
between motivating someone and inspiring
someone I use that as a motivation and I
kept saying in the interviews when we
were building our sister I want people
to see what I'm doing and get up and and
do something similar you know there's so
many different homes with people that I
need in so our
go there spend a day do laundry cook for
them this is what I was trying to do to
motivate them to get up and do something
but that's how I do not define I can
find it too it's so crazy
I've never DJed in my entire life when
he was talking I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] DJ for 61 hours I'm so sick I'm
like such a broken person anyway I
actually am going to use this
opportunity to do something for my
audience that I've wanted to speak about
for a while now which is I don't define
the grind or the hustle in many
different words like I don't think I
think we're getting too caught up in
words especially my community like we're
trying to define all these things you
can call it use the adjective you know
that you want
I think nobody should be confused I
think it's a great parlay off of what
you said I'm trying to show people the
reason I do a daily vlog is sure I'm
narcissistic and wanting on tape and all
that stuff and it builds a brand it'll
be fun to look at when I'm 80 but more
than anything I'm suffocating out
anybody's excuse of what hard work
actually looks like it's on pace now
it's black and white there's no more
debate you guys see it and by the way
I'm so thrilled to do this literally for
28 straight years so that it's so
mundane and boring it's the same old
grime and hustle same old thing and so
whether you use the word grind or hustle
or work or do a little people like Gary
you shouldn't use crush it anymore it's
played out use this or I don't like the
word hustle it could mean like like the
work to debate the word the semantics of
that [ __ ] is such a waste of time just
do the action you understand what it is
if you're debating the word and trying
to have those conversations that's the
excuse to buy times and not actually do
it that's exactly right
lenz thank you so much it's all visible
follow this man slap it up club expands
for a picture hang with us now my friend
oh yeah I'll take that again but now you
get to ask the question of the day every
time I have a guess you get to ask I'm
going to buy you some time all you think
of it you get to ask the question of the
day you know thousands of people across
YouTube and Facebook will answer it you
can use this for market research you can
use this for you can make it just silly
or fun but you get to ask the questions
de and they will answer it so what's
your question for the vaynernation
I think the human generation of humans
in constant sexual happiness and people
find it in different things work and
play
I think my question to everyone and this
question is to spy maybe to get you a
friend and go find your own
what is your happiness oh man he's
climbin up on this wonderful community
you keep asking questions we'll keep
answering
[Music]